[Music]
foreign
the City of Angels
more like the city of dirty little
secrets
people pay me to look into the
activities of its finest citizens
I'm a private detective
the name is Philip Marlowe
how private are your investigations Mr
Marla what can I do for you I'd like you
to find my lover he disappeared without
saying goodbye
haven't we all
[Music]
what does my daughter want my mother was
a wasn't just
she must think there's something between
us
I hear that you are looking for someone
we're all looking for someone I'll pay
you a thousand if you find temps for me
the puzzle has many pieces I don't know
what you're gonna find
I'm going down the rabbit hole I'm not
afraid to take you with me I do like to
think about not being afraid
you should be
they're all in on the conspiracy
looking because you can't stop
the police won't touch you but I will
of all the people in Los Angeles who you
do not mess with they're top of the list
the key to Hollywood is knowing when
your game is up you go in there I'm
coming out alive
I have to ask myself who wins Mr Barlow
I wrote you everything to put you in
jail
[Music]
we all have our secrets
your secret
you'll have to keep those too
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]